[Musik]
von welcher partei sind sie cdu cdu
warum sind wie gegen die er für alle ist
also ausgerichtet dass mann und frau die
er an sich einige fahrer schaffen machen
aber dann besorgt gefangen
sie sehen hier die traditionelle
gefährdet ist die spezies der
homosexuellen nicht viel gefährdet aber
die können sie ja nicht fortpflanzen hat
sie vorrang und in einem netz gespielt
werden so erteilt sein aber man kann's
auch leise immer sagen es tut uns leid
dass ich schwul und lesbisch tritten
leise sein damit der stimme runtergehen
weil man sollte sich doch ein bisschen
dafür schweren es gibt ja diesen satz im
koalitionsvertrag rechtliche regelungen
die gleichgeschlechtliche
lebenspartnerschaft schlechter stellen
werden wir beseitigen welcher
koalitionspartner hat den satz nicht
richtig verstanden für die oder ist für
die cdu
warum setzen sich eigentlich so für die
er einst sind doch sonst gegen
käfighaltung einsätze aber ich finde
wenn jemand heiraten will dann soll er
das tun mit dem er den er liebt dann
soll sie das tun
mit der sie wie sie liebt dann wollen er
das tun mit der sie und sie mit dem eher
egal wer sich liebt und unbedingt
heiraten will
wolltest bitteschön dürfen die werden
schon sehen was sie davon haben
[Musik]
die spd nah was sagt ihnen das ja das
ist zum beispiel das wohnzimmer
angesprochen wenn man es wirklich will
dann müssen wir auch die leute wählen
die das umsatz werden die grünen das
blinken ist die spd zum beispiel wenn es
noch keine idee in dem fall dann nicht
weil er zwar nicht durchgesetzt
ihr habt gut dann vielleicht gerne zu
wählen fdp für mehr ausbauen die oft
eine ganze szene setzen können das war
ich allerdings bezweifeln woran liegt
das denn dass das jetzt nicht klappt es
steht ja im koalitionsvertrag drin
im prinzip ist ja so sie wollen die ehe
für alle wirkten sich aber für die cdu
immer im bild zu bleiben weiter so ein
bisschen also ich sehe es auch so würden
uns natürlich nicht immer aber wir
wollen natürlich die wesentlichen
erfolge der koalition auch bis zum ende
fortsetzen würden sie mich heiraten weil
ich persönlich bin sozusagen ein
wegweiser gehe aber selbst nicht mit und
habe ich kann mich in der fraktion
umhören ob ich jemanden finden wir ein
schöner zufall dass er so ein schönes
zeichen gewesen dass man auch sagt die
spd setzt sich ein für die er für alle
und wir sind sozusagen vorreiter wie
sowas will ich aber noch nicht gehen so
gut kennen uns dann auch nicht kommen
auf die berichterstattung in zukunft
besser wird werden heute schon besser
wegkommen als supermann weichen sehr
gerne was sie achten
[Musik]
zu viel romantik
[Applaus]